thank you
hey
austerity uh
um
[Music]
um
i hear you well thank you
oh yeah
oh
two minute warning on the briefing on
the briefing
yes
um
i mean that's
and personal life watching our masters
99 more days now he thinks that he could
get
50 million people two doses of
vaccine within a hundred days and he
didn't like when he was about whether or
not
uh
good afternoon thank you for joining us
today many familiar faces from yesterday
back again
uh we are pleased uh to have dr fauci
here with us
as part of the president's commitment to
have public health experts
lead our communication with the american
people about the pandemic
just to give you a bit of a run of show
here uh dr fatchi will speak
at the top about the state of the
pandemic the status of vaccines uh he'll
take some of your questions
i will play the role of the bad cop when
it's time for him to go and get to the
work of
the american people and then i will uh
do a topper and i'll answer a bunch of
your questions as well
so there's lots to come after this with
that i will turn it over to dr
fauci
thank you very much and i'm going to
just spend a couple of minutes
just uh summarizing the status of where
we are
and then maybe addressing some of the
things that i know are on people's
minds so first of all obviously we are
still in a very serious situation
i mean to have over 400 000 deaths is
something that you know is
unfortunately historic in the very in
the very bad sense
um when you look at the number of new
infections that we have it's still a
very
very high rate hospitalizations are up
there are certain areas of the country
as i think you're all familiar with
which are really stressed
from the standpoint of beds from the
standpoint of the stress on the health
care system
however when you look more recently
at the seven day average of cases
remember we were going between three and
four hundred thousand and two and three
hundred thousand
right now it looks like it might
actually be
plateauing in the sense of turning
around now
there's good news in that but you have
to be careful
that we may not be seeing perhaps an
artifact an artifact of the slowing down
following the holidays
so when we see that we think it's real
but one of the things and it's
interesting i'm sort of getting a deja
vu standing up here because i said
something like this
almost a little bit less than a year ago
when we were talking about the
the uh acceleration of cases in the late
winter early spring
of 2020 when we were having new york
city metropolitan area being
the epicenter of what was going on that
there are
always lags so please be be aware of
that
that when you have cases and then a
couple of weeks later you'll see it
represented in hospitalizations
intensive care and then a couple of
weeks later
in deaths so you have almost a
paradoxical curves
where you see something plateauing and
maybe coming down
at the same time as hospitalizations and
deaths
might actually be going up so this is
something that i just
put on your radar screen it is not an
unusual thing
to see that sort of thing the other
point i want to make
is one that we're getting asked a lot
regarding questions and that that is
what is it about these mutants that
you're hearing about
the mutants in the uk which we know are
in about 20 plus states
the eu the mutants that we're seeing in
south africa
and in brazil first of all
we need to understand that rna viruses
like
coronaviruses mutate all the time most
of the mutations
don't have any physiological relevance
with regard
to the function of the virus itself
however every once in a while you get
mutations either singly
or clustered in combinations which do
have an impact
so what have we learned thus far and i
want to emphasize thus far because we're
being
very very careful attention to this and
we take it very seriously
at least from the experience that our
colleagues in the uk have had
the one that is in the uk appears to
have
a greater degree of transmissibility
about twice as much as what we call the
wild-type
original virus the one that is
in south africa is a bit different and
i'll get to that in a second
so it does look like it increases the
transmissibility
they say correctly on a one-to-one basis
it doesn't seem to make the virus more
virulent
or have a greater chance of making you
seriously ill
or killing you however we shouldn't be
lulled into complacency about that
because if you have a virus that is more
transmissible
you're going to get more cases when you
get more cases
you're going to get more
hospitalizations i'm going to get more
hospitalizations
you ultimately get more deaths so even
though the virus on a one-to-one basis
isn't more serious the phenomenon of a
more transmissible virus
is something that you take seriously the
next thing
is does it change enough to interfere
with the efficacy of a whole group of
monoclonal antibodies
that many of you are aware of the
monoclonal antibodies that are being
used for treatment in some cases
and prevention since monoclonal
antibodies
bind to a very specific part
of the virus when there's a mutation
there
it has much greater a chance of
obliterating the efficacy
of a monoclonal antibody and we're
seeing in the much more concerning um
uh mutations that are in south africa
and in some respects brazil which is
similar
to south africa that is having an effect
on the monoclonal antibodies the real
question that people
are quite clearly interested in is what
is the impact
on the vaccine and so far
literally we have this new phenomenon
that are prepared
journals where where people get data and
they put it into
a pre-print server where it hasn't yet
been peer reviewed
but you have to pay attention to it
because it gives you good information
quickly ultimately it gets confirmed and
we're seeing them coming out over the
last few days
and what they're saying is that what we
likely will be seeing
is a diminution more south africa than
uk uk is that diminution in what would
be the efficacy
of the vaccine induced antibodies
now that does not mean that the vaccines
will not be effective and let me explain
why
there's a thing called a cushion effect
so if you have a vaccine like the
moderna and the fisa vaccine
that can suppress the virus at a
dilution let's say of
one to a thousand and the mutant
influences it by bringing it down to
maybe one to f
to 800 or something like that you're
still
well above the line of not being
effective
so there's that cushion that even though
it's diminished
somewhat it still is affected
that's what we're seeing both certainly
with the uk which is very minimal
effect with why we're following very
carefully
the one in south africa which is a
little bit more concerning
but nonetheless not something that we
don't think that we can handle
what is the message because someone can
say now wait a minute if you have
the possibility that the vaccines are
diminishing in their
impact why are we vaccinating people no
it is all the more reason why we should
be vaccinating as many people as you
possibly can
because as long as the virus is out
there replicating
viruses don't mutate unless they
replicate
and if you can suppress that by a very
good vaccine campaign then you could
actually
avoid this deleterious effect that you
might get
from the mutations bottom line we're
paying
very close attention to it there are
alternative plans
if we ever have to modify the vaccine
that is not something
that is a very onerous thing we can do
that given the platforms we have
but right now from the reports we have
literally
as of today it appears that the vaccines
will still
be effective against them with the
caveat in mind you want to pay
close attention to it so john why don't
i just stop there and then maybe just
answer some questions on anything else
that i said so
yeah how helpful would it have been if
amazon got
involved with the federal response to
kobe 19
before fiden took office
and do you know about any plans or
discussions ahead of yesterday
no i don't think i could answer that
question
i'd be waving my hands about that sorry
but you know
one of the new things in this
administration is if you don't know the
answer
don't guess just say you don't know the
answer yeah
yes a couple of questions
i'd like to follow up with you uh on
what you just said about this stream in
south africa has that strain made its
way
to the united states and what if any
concerns do you have how much do we
understand about that great question
thus far it does not appear at all that
the south african strain is in the
united states
however we must be honest and say that
the level of comprehensive
sequence surveillance thus far is not at
the level
that we would have liked so we we're
going to be looking very very carefully
for it
but given the information we have today
it doesn't appear that the south african
strain is here okay
if i could just ask you about the effort
to distribute
the vaccines because of course that's
what makes people want to know
when are they going to get a vaccine
is the biden administration starting
from scratch
with the vaccine distribution effort or
are you picking up where the trump
administration left off
no i mean um we certainly are not
starting from scratch because there is
activity going on in the distribution
but if you look at the plan that the
president has put forth
about the things that he's going to do
namely get community vaccine centers up
get pharmacies more involved where
appropriate
get the defense production act involved
not only
perhaps with getting more vaccine but
even the things you need
to get a good vaccine program for
example
needles and syringes that might be more
useful than that
so it's taking what's going on but
amplifying it in a big way
biden said that what was left was
abysmal essentially
i mean is there anything actionable that
you are
taking from the previous administration
does that delay your efforts to get the
vaccine i mean that's the question no
i mean we're coming in with fresh
ideas but also some ideas that were not
bad ideas
with the with the with the previous
administration you can't say it was
absolutely not usable at all so we are
continuing but you're going to see a
real ramping up of it one more final
question you had said that most people
will be vaccinated by
the middle of 2021 is that still your
expectations
yes it is i mean i i believe that the
the goal that was set by the president
of getting a hundred million
people vaccinated in the first hundred
days is quite a reasonable goal
and when you get to the point and and
one of the things that that i think is
is something we need to pay attention to
and i
quite frankly been spending a
considerable amount of my own time
is outreaching particularly to minority
communities
to make sure that you get them to be
vaccinated and you explain why it's so
important for themselves
their family and their community if we
get
70 to 85 percent of the country
vaccinated
let's say by the end of the summer
middle of the summer i believe by the
time we get to the fall
we will be approaching a degree of
normality it's not going to be perfectly
normal
but one that i think will take a lot of
pressure off the american public
you're one of the few holdovers from the
previous administration this term one
what has been your experience with this
new team
and in your view what would have been
different in terms of the trajectory of
this outbreak from the start had a team
like this been in place at the beginning
well i can tell you my
my impression of of of what's going on
right now the team i don't know if i can
extrapolate other things but
one of the things that was very clear as
recently as about 15 minutes ago
when i was with the president is that
one of the things that we're going to do
is to be
completely transparent open and honest
if things go wrong not point fingers but
to correct
them and to make everything we do be
based on
science and evidence i mean that was
literally
a conversation i had 15 minutes ago with
the president
and he has said that multiple times that
you uh
looking back on your comments over the
last 10 or 12 months
would like to now with that sort of
license to to to amend or clarify
no i mean i i always said everything on
the base that's why i got in trouble
sometimes
you mentioned pharmacies uh the new cdc
director said today that the goal of
getting vaccinations
into pharmacies by the end of next month
isn't realistic as had been previously
suggested
when will most americans be able to get
a vaccination
in their neighborhood pharmacy well i'm
i didn't hear that comment are you
talking about dr wolinski's comment i i
didn't hear that comment so i don't
really want to
comment on on the comment but what she
may be saying
is that for many people in this country
who don't have access
to a pharmacy they may not be able to
utilize getting things in the pharmacy i
i'm not sure i want to be careful
because i'm not sure that's what she
said
we just had a conversation about how
we're going to get
vaccines to people who are in pharmacy
desert areas
where they don't have easy access to a
pharmacy and that's something we're
working on and taking very seriously
just to be clear if you are in an area
where you do have access to a cbs or a
wall right when will you be able to to
get
back to access to this vaccine like you
would a flu vaccine you know in the
spirit of
nothing i really i'm not quite sure when
that will be but we can get back to you
on that
just on the broader timeline you
mentioned the fall we just heard the
president say you know the brutal truth
is that it is going to be several more
months
just to be clear you're saying by the
fall the majority of americans no you
think we'll be back
no i didn't say that i said if we get
the majority of americans 70 to 85
vaccinated by then we could have a
degree of herd immunity that would get
us back to normal
the concern i have and something we're
working on
is getting people who have vaccine
hesitancy who don't want to get
vaccinated
because many people are skeptical about
that so we really need to do a lot of
good
outreach for that i mean i don't know
what the best case
the best case scenario for me is that
we'd get 85 percent of the people
vaccinated by the end of the summer
if we do then by the time we get to the
fall i think we can approach a degree of
normality
on that mutations that you were talking
about a question about how exactly
they increase transmissibility is it
does it take
less exposure time together what it is
is that you can do
in vitro in a in a test tube setting
binding an affinity to the receptors
which you have in your nose in your
lung and your gi tract the receptor for
the virus is called an
ace ii receptor and the facility or
affinity with which a virus
binds to that means that it very likely
will have a better efficiency
of infection and replicate more in the
nasopharynx
so that's how you make that
determination in the test tube
then you look epidemiologically and you
see a spike going up in the sense
of number of cases and they sort of
match each other
a virus that has the inability to easily
bind to
and replicate with your receptors is one
that likely will spread easier
it doesn't mean that you'd have more
viral load
oh you could yes in fact it would mean
because if it binds more easily
it could replicate in the nasopharynx
more easily and it is likely that you
would have a higher viral load
make masks less effective in that case
no it makes it the reason
why you absolutely should be wearing a
mask it doesn't necessarily make it
less effective if you properly wear a
mask then you'll be okay
the uk stream do you have any any data
on how widespread that strain is in
at the united states that people have
mentioned exactly
the the real question that's going to be
asked is it going to become the dominant
strain
or will the strains we already have
prevent it from flourishing
and being in the more dominant strain
but it is here for sure
um just a follow-up on vaccines some
state and local
authorities are saying that they would
be able to distribute more vaccines if
they had
more is the biden administration now
trying to increase
production by moderna and pfizer in the
next six weeks
yeah as well as to utilize what we hope
will be another player in the field the
j and j johnson as well as other of the
companies
but also as the as the president has
said in his plan
to do whatever he can to expand the
availability
of vaccines whatever that is i mean he
said that he's going to just use every
possibility
including the defense production act can
you explain the discrepancy between what
some states are saying
about needing more vaccines in the cdc
saying that a lot of vaccine is still
remaining on people's
or on their shelves yeah you know i i
think that
that is something that we need to really
take a close look at because that is
sort of an inconsistent
discrepancy and one of the things we
want to do is to find out
why that's the case and if it is the
case particularly
the thing that would be most disturbing
if there's vaccine
laying around and people are not using
it when others
would need it but i don't know the
answer to that question but we need to
look into it
doctor fountain you've joked a couple
times
today already about the difference in
that you feel and being
kind of the spokesperson for this issue
in this administration versus the
previous one
can you can you talk a little bit about
how free
how much different do you feel less
constrained
what is the you know i mean you you for
so many times you stood up behind the
podium with donald trump standing
behind you that was a different that was
a different
feeling i'm sure that it is today can
you talk a little bit about
about how you feel uh
kind of released from from what you had
been doing for the last year
yeah but you said i was joking about it
i was very serious
about it i wasn't joking um you know
actually
i mean i mean obviously i don't want to
be going back
you know over history but it was very
clear that there were things that were
said
uh be it regarding things like
hydroxychloroquine
and other things like that that really
was uncomfortable because they were not
based on scientific fact
i can tell you i i take no pleasure at
all
in being in a situation of contradicting
the president so it was really something
that you didn't feel that you could
actually say something and there
wouldn't be any repercussions about it
the idea
that you can get up here and talk about
what you know
what the evidence what the science is
and know that's it
let the science speak it is somewhat of
a liberating field
basically banished for for a few months
uh there for a while like
you feel like you're back now i think so
wow okay that's mike sheer you don't
want to take
[Laughter]
well thank you everyone as i promised
we'll have a full briefing from here
so uh as you know uh just a few
moments ago uh the president uh also
released
a national covet 19 strategy and signed
10 executive orders and other directives
to move quickly to contain the crisis
underpinning everything the president
signed today and everything we do every
day will be equity
some highlights of those actions include
an executive order to fill
supply shortfalls for vaccinations
testing and ppe
the president directed agencies to
exercise all appropriate authorities
including the defense production act
to accelerate manufacturing and
delivering of supplies such as n95
mast gowns gloves pcr swabs
test reagents and necessary equipment
and material for the vaccine
the president also signed a presidential
memorandum
to increase federal reimbursement to
states and tribes for the cost
of national guard personnel emergency
supplies and the personnel
and equipment needed to create
vaccination centers
an executive order that established a
covet 19 pandemic testing board
to bring the full force of the federal
government's expertise to expanding
testing supply and increasing access to
testing
an executive order to bolster access to
covet 19
treatments and clinical care
establishing a comprehensive
and coordinated pre-clinical drug
discovery and development program to
allow therapeutics to be evaluated
and developed in response to pandemic
threats
sorry i had to clear my throat there's a
lot here um he also
issued an executive order directing the
department of education and health and
human services
to provide guidance on safe reopening
and operating for schools
child care providers and institutions of
higher education
an executive order on the occupational
safety and health administration
to immediately release clear guidance
for employers to help keep workers safe
from covet 19 exposure
an executive order to require mass
squaring in airports or certain modes of
public transportation
including many trains airplanes maritime
vessels and intercity
buses and an executive order
establishing a coven 19 health equity
tasks were something we had previously
announced but making it official today
to provide specific recommendations to
the president for allocating resources
and funding in communities with
inequities and coveted 19 outcomes
by race ethnicity geography disability
and other considerations these steps
of course build on the actions we
announced yesterday i had an additional
update uh some of you may have seen this
come out through last late last night
uh but i wanted to share with you that
as a result of one of the executive
orders
president of biden signed uh yesterday
the acting homeland security
secretary issued a memorandum to review
and reset immigration enforcement
priorities
for 100 days beginning tomorrow the
department of homeland security will
pause removals
for certain individuals this pause will
allow the administration to review
and reset enforcement policies and
ensure that resources
are dedicated to the most pressing
challenges and that we have a fair and
effective
for enforcement system rooted in
responsibly managing the border and
protecting our national security
and public safety i had one other item i
just wanted to flag for you
about something the first lady is up to
let me see if i can find that or i will
circle back to it
a little bit later with that i'm happy
to take your question zeke why don't you
kick us off
thanks jen um some reporting earlier
today about uh
the president's commitment to uh
extending a really
extending new start do you talk about
what uh the president's directive on
that front has been
additionally um did he uh he confirmed
that the president requested reports
from the
new dni uh for an assessment on central
party interference in the 2020 election
and also the solar winds
act i can confirm that the united states
intends to seek a five-year extension of
new start as the treaty permits
the president has long been clear that
the new start treaty
is in the national security interests of
the united states
and this extension makes even more sense
when the relationship with russia is
adversarial as it is at this time
nustar is the only remaining treaty
constraining russian nuclear forces
and is an anchor of strategic stability
between our two countries and to the
other part of your question
um even as we work with russia to
advance
u.s interests so too we work to hold
russia to account for its reckless and
adversarial actions
and to this end the president is also
issuing issuing a tasking to the
intelligence community for its full
assessment
of the solar winds cyber breach russian
interference in the 2020 election
its use of chemical weapons against
opposition leader
alexey navalny and the alleged bounties
on u.s soldiers in afghanistan
so that's hopefully answered all of it
that was a mouthful and then just a
change of years for colton uh to
code in the negotiations with capitol
hill how long is the president willing
to pursue bipartisanship democrats are
already talking about the reconciliation
process is there
given the critical need for some sort of
aid here the president's talking about
is there a deadline at which he's going
he's getting republicans you know
but you know it is it is it february 1st
is it presence
weekend uh by which i'll say no reduced
by reconciliation instead
well i'm not going to set any deadlines
on our first full day in office
uh but i will say and hopefully i'll
have more for all of you on this
tomorrow
uh we are going to be uh increasing our
engagement it's already been ongoing
even before the president was
inaugurated yesterday but
hopefully we'll have more to share with
you tomorrow on meetings engagements
um discussions that will be going on
with leaders on capitol hill and many
members over the course of the next
several days
as i conveyed to all of you uh yesterday
uh
his preference uh and priority is
a bipartisan package and working with
members of both
parties to come to agreement on that
because he believes
that the crises facing the american
people
as we saw the jobs numbers this morning
the unemployment insurance claims i
should say we put out a statement by
our nec director in case you didn't see
that as we've seen and the reports from
dr
fauci just a few minutes ago this is
this crisis is dire
and it requires uh immediate action and
we hope and expect
members of both parties to work together
to do that we're also not going to take
options off the table uh so we'll
proceed with those discussions over the
next couple of days
go ahead chris jeff i can just follow up
on that there was some reporting that
there was going to be a meeting
this weekend with a bipartisan group of
lawmakers can you give us any indication
is that going to happen with president
biden or with his economic team is that
your
expectation well i think the reporting
was around a meeting
with nec director brian diese i spoke
with him earlier today he is
definitely going to be engaging with a
range of members and a range of
different groups of members from capitol
hill in the coming days uh i think we
were still working to confirm specific
meetings before i came out here and i
hope to have more
for all of you on that by tomorrow and
more broadly speaking
jen president biden has proposed this
1.9 trillion dollar package
you already have some republicans who
say we just passed a stimulus plan
they're not going to get
on board with this mitt romney among
them who says you just passed a program
with over
900 billion dollars and some people say
the price tag is just way too big
so how does president biden expect to
get this task with bipartisan support
and how does that fit
his broader message of bipartisanship
proposing something like this specific
well i
think it fits perfectly into his message
of bipartisanship he wants to work with
democrats and republicans to address the
crises that the american people
are facing whether they live in red
states or blue states or
democratic democrats or republicans
the package was designed based on
recommendations from
health experts from economists
it's been applauded by everyone from
senator bernie sanders to the chamber of
commerce
and there are specific pieces in there
that are meant to serve as a bridge for
the american people
including a large percentage of it
that's for unemployment insurance
uh funding for vaccine distribution
something that is pivotal as we've
already been discussing here today
for reopening of schools so part of the
discussion we'll be having
with members is what what do you want to
cut uh and
uh this is a plan that he feels
addresses the crisis at the moment one
quick follow-up
on that the work of the senate is being
held up by this dispute over
the filibuster where does president
clinton come down on that
does he think that there should not be a
filibuster so that the senate would be
foreign
well the president elect spoke just
yesterday as you all saw about
the spirit of working together and
bipartisanship
to confront the four crises facing us
you've already seen him
work with republicans and democrats and
work toward a bipartisan approach to
passing
packages that will address the crises
we're facing and that certainly is his
priority in his preference
uh so that's what he'll continue to work
on on day two of the administration
go ahead next year okay see you can call
him
i just gave you a heart attack that's
fine um so i want to push you a little
bit more on on that question
if there's this call for unity that
the president made in his speech
yesterday but there has
so far been almost no bid leave even to
the republican party
you don't have a republican cabinet
member like president obama
obama and i think president clinton had
you
you know the executive orders that he's
come out the gate have been
largely designed at erasing as much of
the
trump legacy as as you can with
executive orders
much of which the republican party likes
and agrees with you've
put forth a an immigration bill that has
a path to citizenship but doesn't
do much of a nod towards the border
security and you've got a 1.9 trillion
dollar
uh covered relief bill that has as folks
have said
already drawn all sorts of criticism
where is the where is the actual
action behind this idea of
bipartisanship
and when when are we going to see one of
those you know
sort of substantial outreaches that says
this is something that
you know the republicans want to do too
well
i guess what i would send back to
there's a lot in there so let me do my
best here but
uh mike is is unemployment insurance
only an issue that democrats in the
country
want do only democrats want their kids
to go back to schools
uh do only democrats want vaccines to be
distributed across the country
that's we feel that that package he
feels that package is designed
for bipartisan support i will also say
that we've also had some
uh positive developments um on our
confirmations and our nominees uh last
night as you all saw
uh his not the president's nominee uh
now confirmed
leader first female leader of the
intelligence community was confirmed
with a vote of 85 to 10 84 to 10. you
can check me on that
but an overwhelming vote um we've seen
progress today
on on the nomination and hopeful
confirmation of
lloyd austin so there is movement um
supported by both
sides of the aisle and members of both
parties i think if you talk to democrat
or republicans on the hill which i know
many of you do
they will say they're not looking for
something symbolic
they're looking for engagement they're
looking to have a conversation they're
looking to have a dialogue
and that's exactly what he's going to do
go ahead on that has the president
reached out to congressional leaders to
sit down and
discuss this relief package will he be
how much personal involvement is he
gonna have in this process
i expect he will be rolling up his
sleeves and will be quite involved in
this process mary
and he was yesterday was quite a busy
day for him as you all know um his
schedule was minute by minute and his
family was here uh but he was involved
even before yesterday
having conversations with members of
both parties uh picking up the phone
and having those conversations uh he saw
of course members of both parties he
invited leaders from both parties to
join him at church
obviously that wasn't really a
discussion about uh specifics of the
bill
but they did he did have an opportunity
to talk about his agenda and working to
for
working together on his agenda moving
forward but i think he will see him
quite involved in the days ahead
but you will also see the vice president
uh quite involved you will also see
um policy leaders like brian deese and
others
in the administration quite involved and
having conversations with both democrats
and republicans
right now to sit down with them well i i
think we'll have more to share with you
soon
uh in terms of engagement of many of our
senior officials with members of both
parties and on the defense production
act just to be clear has the
administration actually invoked the
defense production act
and if so can you spell out what changes
we may see because of this
which companies are being asked to make
what
well let me give you a very specific
example that helped really make it clear
for me
um one area is to acquire
more low low dead volume syringes and
what that does
is these specialized syringes allow
pharmacists and vaccinators to extract
an extra dose
of the pfizer vial so making more doses
available
of course it also prioritizes the
defense production act
raw materials that are used to produce
the vaccine so
reducing bottlenecks um and it enables
uh
manufacturers uh us to empower
uh and invoke i guess an uh action from
manufacturers to make sure we have
the materials we need to get the
vaccines out the door and in the arms of
americans in terms of obviously he
signed it this afternoon
um i'll have to just circle back with
you on what it mean if it's officially
invoked in this moment or if it takes
some time and we can we can circle back
with you after the birthing
go ahead um stimulus is the white house
drafting a legislative film
you mean in terms of the the what he
announced last week
last thursday will he announce what his
specific ideas will be and what his
vision is
but right now we're having discussions
with members of both parties as we have
for the last week about
uh what that will look like okay so no
no bill draft coming out of the white
house as well
well um i'll i'm happy to talk to our
legislative team about that i think what
was important
um to the president was to outline what
his vision would be this is how the
process should actually work
right the president outlines here's the
my vision here's what i think should be
in a package
let's have discussions uh let's have
engagements with both parties and let's
see
what comes out of the sausage making at
the other side ahead
i'll come back to you i'm sorry i can't
even see you but um just following up on
what kristen
asked i don't think i heard an answer
about whether the president supports
uh keeping the filibuster where he sits
on that is he has he talked to senator
schumer about that and he served there a
long time
what are his thoughts on that i think
what i was conveying to kristin is that
uh the president has been clear he wants
to work with members of both parties and
find bipartisan paths forward and
um i don't have any more conversations
to read out for you at this point
specifically answer that unless i'm not
understanding your answer i don't think
i have more more to add to
my answer and then just on the
impeachment trial
um i know that there was some talk about
sort of the senate doing both
both things at the same time two things
at once there's some reporting this
afternoon
that republicans are pushing to have the
impeachment trials start in february
where do you all stand still now on that
are you still looking for that
uh both paths to happen at the same time
would it be preferable to do that first
or
are you okay with with later as as some
republicans
well i need i think we we have been
pretty consistent that we believe
the timing and the mechanisms for
the congress and the senate moving
forward and
holding the former president accountable
we'll leave that to them
and what our biggest priority and focus
is is
ensuring that it doesn't delay
the senate congress moving forward in uh
consideration
and discussion around uh the coveted
relief package that the president
proposed last week
uh go ahead thank you chad it's a
principle or i have a question for
myself and then a question for someone
who cannot be here because of the social
distance insurance
my question is this and it's about unity
again i've heard
from conservatives who are afraid that
the president is going to try to pull
back
religious conscience exemptions for
groups like little sisters of the poor
the president pledged he would do that
in july when the little sisters won
a case in the supreme court uh the
health and human services
nominee javier visera pursued that line
of going going after the exemptions as
attorney general of california
what's the president going to do on that
i haven't discussed that particular
issue with him i'm happy to circle back
with you but
i i don't there's not a change in his
position from what he said earlier this
summer
did you have another question question
from adam longa of
wusa9 he says we saw the president
warmly greet mayor bowser during the
parade yesterday she is pushing for the
d.c statehood measure
to be on the president's desk within 100
days will the administration get behind
this bill
and does the president support it i hate
to disappoint you
but i will have to circle back with you
on that as well there's quite a bit
going on i have not discussed dc
statehood with him in the last 36 hours
go ahead and back yeah thanks jeff um i
wanted to circle back on something
related uh i know the president has
obviously made a priority of
uh getting resume in person learning in
the first 100 days i wonder
is the administration planning to issue
any kind of
uniform guidance to states on you know
whether it's reopening schools reopening
businesses
indoor dining stuff like that or are you
all planning to just kind of
leave it to states to do sort of a
patchwork based on their own situations
well uh as dr fauci conveyed
our objective is to uh ensure that
health and medical experts are
leading the effort in delivering
guidance determining guidance and also
communicating it with the public
whenever possible
and any guidance would come of course as
you know from the cdc
uh we and we will we will of course
defer to that
uh but part of our priority and our
focus here is on
uh providing more uh engagement with
states
uh more clear guidance uh from the
federal level
uh in terms of how we're planning to
operate what data we're seeing
uh how the how vaccines are being
distributed what we see is the
challenges
and that communication has been lacking
as we understand it from our
conversations in the past few months so
that is what we will
focus on improving in the months ahead
would you specifically are you planning
to do you know
daily or weekly calls with states or how
are you planning to
well we have an entire cova team as you
know who are now most of them are
official and part of their
role will be engaging with governors
democrats and republicans
uh mayors local elected officials to
have gained a better understanding of
what's happening on the ground
that will be how they're going to be in
taking a great deal of information
obviously health
care providers and experts on the ground
as well we will also do engagement
from the level of the president and the
vice president as well because they also
want to have that
conversation with states and local
officials on
what they're experiencing what they see
the challenges as and
uh and how they can be addressed and you
know that's something
i think in president biden's heart he is
a local
elected official still and and he gets
into the weeds of what they're
experiencing and i and he will be
involved in that himself go ahead thanks
john
there's a lot of really big things that
the administration wants to do
infrastructure
the stimulus uh tax reform can you sort
of lay out the cadence for us over the
upcoming year
how do you envision those three major
things playing out what's the order when
do you think those will
be taken up but when will that happen
well uh what i can lay out for you on
our first full day here is what our
initial priorities are
um and they revolve around addressing
the four crises that the president
has stated that the country is facing
including
getting the pandemic under control
getting people back to work
addressing our climate crisis and
addressing uh
racial equity
i was gonna ask you do you think tax
reform happens in 2021
i don't really have any predictions for
you on that um i
i think at this point in time and for
the foreseeable future
uh addressing the pandemic getting the
pandemic under control
uh and that linkage to uh getting people
back to work will be
his top priority keystone xl the
decision uh yesterday from the president
what would you say to those who have
lost their job or will lost their job
as a result of that decision what would
the message from the president in the
white house
the message of the president in the
white house would be that he is
uh committed his record will show shows
the american people that he's committed
to
uh clean energy jobs uh to jobs that
are not only good high-paying jobs
uh union jobs but ones that are also
good for our environment he thinks it's
possible to do both uh he
led an effort when he was the vice
president uh
to put millions of people to work with
those
both of those priorities in mind and he
will continue to
do that as president uh but he had
opposed the keystone pipeline
back in 2013 uh when it was when there
was a consideration
of the permit or sorry i don't think it
was 2013 i think it was a little bit
after that
uh and he's been consistent in his view
and he was delivering on a promise he
made to the american public during the
campaign
um go ahead all the way in the back
thank you i wanted to ask you about
india's relationship uh what is
president biden's vision of an india or
u.s relationship
the relationship between the world's
oldest and world's largest democrats
well first i would say that president
biden
who of course has visited india many
times
respects and values the long bipartisan
uh successful relationship between
leaders in india and the united states
um he looks forward to a continuation of
that
obviously he selected and uh and
yesterday
she was sworn in um the first uh
indian-american
uh to serve as president or vice
president certainly a historic moment
uh for all of us in this country but uh
a further
um you know cementing of the importance
of our uh relationship
so go ahead george yep thanks uh
two questions like one on the on the
hatch act
will this administration take that
seriously and do you think it's ever
appropriate
for this white house to have a political
event or political meeting well
as you know there are some political
events that are
acceptable but we certainly take the
hatch act seriously
uh and will abide by that and
you will not see a political uh rally
on the south lawn of the white house
with president under president biden
second one this this may sound trivial
but
presidents and candidates have some
events where
they're fun for the candidate the big
crowd
and the acceptance speech at the
convention the big crowd
at the inauguration big rallies
because of kobe this president has
been denied all those has he ever been
at all wistful about sort of missing the
fun parts of
being a candidate and the inauguration
not not not in front of me george i i
will say that even yesterday
um or of the last couple of days you
know he tried to find a moment of joy
uh with his family and with his
grandchildren who bring him great a
great deal of joy
and a recognition of uh
of course the great responsibility he
has on his shoulders but
a a moment in history uh that
uh that he was uh playing a very
important part of so
i would say he's been in public office
as you all know for decades
and he's had many joyful moments but
this moment serving as president coming
in
at a crisis where thousands of people
are dying from a pandemic
every day millions of people are out of
work
is not really a time for daily joy as
the leader of the free world and he's
focused on
on doing his job to get the work done
for the american people go ahead
why weren't president biden and all
members of the biden family matched
at all times on federal lands last night
if he signed
an executive order that mandates masks
on federal
lands at all times at the inaugural
memorial i guess i i think steven
was celebrating uh an evening a
of a historic day in our country and
certainly he signed the mask mandate
because
it's a way to send a message to the
american public about
the importance of uh wearing masks how
it can save tens of thousands of lives
we take a number of coveted precautions
as you know here in terms of
testing social distancing mask wearing
ourselves as
as we do every single day but i don't
know that i have more for you on it than
that
but as uh joe biden often talks about uh
it is not just important the uh example
of
power but the power of our example was
that a good example for people who are
watching who might not pay attention
uh normally well steve i think uh
the power of his example is also uh the
message he sends by
signing 25 executive orders including
almost
half of them related to kovid uh the
requirements that we're all under every
single day here to ensure we're sending
that message to the public
yesterday was a historic moment in our
history he was inaugurated as president
of the united states he was surrounded
by his family
we take a number of precautions but i
don't think
i think we have big bigger issues to to
worry about at this moment in time
go ahead anita you mentioned oh sorry
jeff
let me go to jeff and yeah because i
already want to see if that's okay
thanks very much um
follow up on new start do you have any
indication from russia that they will
object to
um the extension of five years and has
the united states already alerted moscow
about its desire
uh well we have not uh obviously as you
know a number of our nominees have
talked about our intention
during their confirmation hearings over
the past couple of days of
extending new start uh i don't have any
calls to read out for you but i
can check and see if any uh
notifications or discussions have
happened this afternoon
and a follow-up on something from
yesterday which i think you refer to if
president biden had said that president
trump left him a very generous note
and he didn't want to talk about it
until he spoke to president trump
are president biden and president former
president trump
going to have a call there's no call
plans uh what he was conveying
is that he didn't want to release a
private note
uh without having agreement from the
former president
but i wouldn't say he's seeking it
through a phone call he just was
even trying to be respectful uh in that
moment of a private letter that was sent
with regard to the former president has
president biden spoke to speaker pelosi
at all about the timing
of when she plans to bring the
impeachment articles to the senate and
how he would like to see this trial
proceed
president biden has been pretty clear
about what the focus of his
conversations are and what his intention
is with his engagements with
leaders from both sides of the aisle and
in both houses of congress including
with speaker pelosi someone he's known
for quite some time
and that is his intention and focus on
getting uh the uh kovid package through
uh so he will leave it to her and to
uh now uh leader schumer to determine
what the path forward and the timeline
will be in holding the former president
accountable
uh anita go back to you yeah you uh
earlier mentioned
four priorities of the president i was
surprised
to not hear immigration for saying that
because yesterday many of the executive
orders were about immigration
there were two major agency releases
last night about immigration
the bill is being introduced today do
you not see that as sort of the second
big push after the coven bill
where do you see that and i guess i
would say why is it i was going to ask
you why
is it going to be you know why is it
such a priority after the covenant bill
but you didn't even list it so i wanted
to kind of clarify that and get your
thoughts on it
well i i wouldn't i wouldn't uh read
into that other than immigration we
consider as part of racial equity
um and part of uh which is a broad
issue but that's how the president has
spoken about
uh that crisis over the past several
months and clearly it is an enormous
priority
to him because uh he we moved forward in
announcing the specifics
of an immigration bill an immigration
package he is
eager to move forward on with congress
on his first day in office
but as you know there's been a lot of
history on efforts to
do comprehensive immigration reform to
do any form of immigration reform and
what we're hopeful is that this will be
a moment of reset
and a moment to restart discussions on
capitol hill
there are already a number of
co-sponsors who have been announced
to have those discussions there are
experts on immigration who have
worked on this issue on both sides of
the aisle historically it is an issue
there that there is bipartisan support
support from the business community
supports from from a range of outside
groups with uh
with different uh political tilts uh and
we're hopeful that that will help propel
it forward
mendez said today on a call he called it
a herculean
you know effort to get this through as
you know it hasn't gone through as you
just
mentioned before i mean there are
republicans
grumbling today that there's not more in
that bill that they want to see so
is that bill what do you think the
prospect of that bill getting through
is well i don't know that i can predict
that the first
day i mean it's only been out for 24
hours um but
what was important to the president in
the outline of this bill
is that it is addressing a couple of
areas that he doesn't feel have been
effectively done in the past
the last four years the immigration
policy has been
based around funding for a wall that has
not worked even to keep the country
safer
even to keep bad actors out and so
his approach is multi-pronged it is to
do smart security
security that will help address and use
technology to address
key border crossings address ports of
entry
uh more effectively and efficiently and
putting that oversight in the hands of
the
department of homeland security it will
also um
help address root causes of migration
and that hasn't been in past bills as
you probably well know anita i
was not in the bill in 2013 but it's
something that he has been an advocate
for in his time in public office
and it also has a pathway to citizenship
for the amount
11 million undocumented immigrants who
are living in the country
there are components of here in the bill
that address
a lot of the issues um that have not
been addressed in the past and and
certainly um
the components of it uh that that make
that are talk about smart security
are the kind of border security that we
think um is essential and more effective
than what we've seen over the past
couple of years
you just elaborate a little about why
the president isn't setting the bar a
little bit higher
you may be a little hard on others just
to explain the other people they see
these statistics of you
one tracker had 1.6 million yesterday
why is the president shooting a little
bit higher given the magnitude of the
crisis here
well none of us are mathematicians
myself included so i asked our
team to do a little math on this so the
trump administration was given 36
million doses
when they were in office for 38 days
they administered a total of about 17
million shots that's about
less than 500 000 shots a day what we
are proposing is to
double that to about 1 million uh
shots per day and we we have outlined
this goal and objective
in coordination and consultation with
our health and medical experts so
it is uh ambitious it's something that
we feel is bold
and was called that certainly at the
time uh and we're
working overtime to help to achieve it
try to achieve it but
it is present trying to we obviously try
to exceed that if possible is it is it
possible
to see it in you know in a couple of
weeks or months
without that goal well there are a lot
of factors that go into
determining how many shots can get into
the arms of americans we feel
confident we can achieve this goal
obviously there are
other vaccines that are being considered
at this point in time by the fda
there is funding that will be needed for
distribution there are a number of steps
that will help
expedite at some point in time but right
now
our focus is on uh what many health
health and medical experts have
consistently called a bold goal
i will note also that some of the
reporting this morning which kristen
asked about earlier was that
the trump administration left us with no
plan it's hard for them to both be
exactly true at the same time um and our
team has been
putting together a plant our own plan as
dr fauci talked about
for some time to achieve this goal uh
but he also mentioned that there are a
number of challenges it's not just about
lining people up
as you all know but for people watching
um in a football stadium and giving them
shots we have to overcome vaccine
hesitancy we have to get to
health uh communities where there aren't
they don't have access to health centers
that was outlined a number of steps to
address that were outlined in the
president's
plan today um but um you know
we this is a bold goal we're going to
work every day to achieve it and
we'll build from there there's a lot
more of the administration to go from
there and more work uncover to be done
go ahead kristen
president biden is reversing a number of
former president trump's policies
and we're seeing some of for president
trump's staffers being placed on leave
or
be reassigned is there an attempt to
purge trump officials well there's a
new administration so obviously there
are a number of new officials in place
uh i know there was some reporting for
example and i don't know if this is who
you're referencing so you tell me if not
uh
of the head of the nlrb um that's an
individual who was not
um carrying out the um uh
you know anyone would tell you not just
from our administration uh the
objectives of
uh the nlrb and so they were they're no
longer in their position
and we'll we'll take make those
decisions as needed
writ large but you're assessing
reassessing and developing
as you know when a new administration
comes in there's a massive change over
in political appointees and nominees
and and people who will serve in a
variety of roles
there are some people christopher wray
as an example i'll just bring him back
up who will continue to serve in his
role
uh but uh we have great value for career
officials for
the officials who have been the heart
and soul of agencies across
government since long before the trump
administration but who have served
through the trump administration as well
did the transition officials know before
yesterday did amazon want to get
involved in such a meaningful way
not that i'm aware of i'm i'm happy to
check i mean when the reporting came out
i asked the question and i think uh
internally and you know what
was conveyed to me and i don't think we
discussed this yesterday was that
we've had a lot of outreach um some
privately some publicly from a range of
businesses and private sector entities
and we certainly welcome that
and uh we'll be considering all of those
offers and what makes the most sense in
our
uh plans and proposals there are some
trump officials saying they were never
offered help from amazon and so they're
essentially saying they think this was a
political call for amazon to wait
while lives were hanging the balance but
you're saying that
it's not the case i'm not aware of the
timeline of when amazon reached out that
sounds like a question for amazon to me
what did you think about all the pardons
that trump handed out on his way out the
door and do you know if the doj or
anyone is reviewing any of those
uh well as you know we nominated an
attorney general just a couple of weeks
ago merrick garland uh we're eager to
get him confirmed
um in the coming weeks hopefully soon uh
we our view on the pardons
uh jennifer is that it's not the way
it's not a model for how a
biden justice department would work it's
not a model i should say for how
president biden would use his own power
he would use his own power far more
judiciously
but we are looking forward and
most important for us and for him is
that
the justice department as we look ahead
is independent
uh makes decisions of their own accord
including their review of
any investigations or uh judicial steps
that have been taken
thank you okay i think we're about to
conclude here but because it's my second
day let's take two more questions
go ahead and it's back
is the president going to listen to the
party attorney um president
bush told president obama that he should
use the pardon power early on
but we know that uh that the pardon
power has been in disrepute in the last
week
because of president trump's parties
what is president going to try to use
the power quickly or i mean you said
judiciously
what's what's his take going to be well
judiciously and i'm not saying you're
conveying this but just for clarity it's
not meant to
in convey speed it's just meant to
convey how he approaches it
as you know he has a long history on uh
judicial issues having served as the
chairman of the judiciary committee many
years ago
uh but on day two i don't have any
prediction for you
in terms of how he would use a pardon
attorneys or the role
but he has great respect for and value
for
uh independence as you know um and for
the role of the judiciary
um and the independence of that role
okay last last actual question sorry
i appreciate it i'm gonna bounce all
stuff here of conversations that may or
may not have happened
can you tell us this president biden
spoke to the fed chair jay powell if he
hasn't
does he have any plans on speaking to
him at any point in the near future and
generally speaking how does the
president view
the stewardship of the fed chair during
this economic crisis
i don't have any calls to read out for
you or to predict for you
with the chairman of the federal reserve
he clearly has a great deal of respect
and value for the federal reserve and
the role they've played historically
given he nominated the former chair
to serve as the first female treasury
secretary um but
i don't have anything more for you i can
venture to get more for you
from our economic team thank you
everyone i'll see you again tomorrow bye